in this video I'll be giving an example
of a non rational number if the square
root of two were a rational number then
by definition it must be expressed as
the ratio of two integers if we then
square both sides we have two equals a
squared divided by B squared if we
multiply both sides by B squared we have
2 B squared equals a squared and from
this we know that a squared is even a
squared is even because we have 2 times
some integer which is B squared since a
squared is even we know that a is even
because a squared equals 2 times some
integer the integer I chose was 2 K
squared that means that a times a can be
expressed as 2 K times 2 K which is to
say that a equals 2k I can now
substitute 2 times 2k squared for a
squared and that leaves us with B
squared equals 2k squared
once these twos cancel out now this also
means that B squared is even because B
squared equals 2 times some integer
which is to say that B is also even
following this same logic now if we go
back to our original premise the square
root of 2 equals a divided by B where a
divided by B is an irreducible fraction
but since a is an even number and B is
also an even number we can express these
numbers as 2 K and 2l but these twos
here will reduce meaning that we'll have
the square root of 2 equals K divided by
L but since this reduced since this is
no longer explicitly represented as a
divided by B and it reduced to K divided
by L we know that we do not have a
rational number now there's a more
specific way to define these numbers or
classify these numbers but we need set
operators in the next video